Birchbox is one of the hottest startups
in new york in 2010 Hayley Varna and
Katya Beauchamp started the company of
students for Business School nearly five
years later it's valued at half a
billion dollars samples have never been
used the way that we're using them we're
absolutely retraining women and men to
think about beauty and grooming
differently every month Birchbox is
eight hundred thousand boxes filled with
beauty samples raking in at least 96
million dollars in sales and that's just
from its female customers it also sells
men's boxes and offers full-sized
products on its website Birchbox works
with more than 800 Beauty companies that
the founders say they'll still fight for
brands attention even that we run a big
business in just a few short years
there's a lot bigger businesses out
there that our brand partners are still
really focused on and we need them to
focus on Birchbox one way they do that
is through their office our goal with
this office was to have it feel like a
start-up but also like a fashion company
so when our beauty brands come here for
meetings that are impressed by the style
but they're also impressed that you know
we're new were disruptive we're scrappy
and innovative Birchbox has had four
offices since settling in New York City
I like to say that we're a hermit crab
but keeps on outgrowing their shell when
we moved into this office and I looked
around and I saw the space it was like a
physical manifestation of everything
that we've created where the 200
employees work in Birch boxes New York
headquarters doing everything from
writing code to writing ads for people
working in startups
work in life it's not black and white
it's grey and we want things to feel
comfortable and homey
they've got the startup standards like a
ping-pong table and unlimited coffee and
a gong an employees can relax on swings
pump iron in the office gym or get down
to business and creative conference
rooms I think that people are most
productive when they feel like they can
be themselves so if they want to sit on
a bouncy ball and if that's going to
mean they do better work we're all for
that